en este vídeo vamos a pensar en dividir
números donde el cociente el resultado
de nuestra división podría resultar en
un decimal así que digamos que queremos
calcular cuánto es 5 dividido entre 2 en
el pasado podrías haber dicho 2 por 2
son 4 y te queda 1 así que podrías haber
dicho esto es igual a 2 con un residuo
de 1 pero ahora no queremos decir
cuántas veces cabe y cuánto queda
queremos saber exactamente cuántas veces
cabe 2 en 5 por lo que queremos una
respuesta decimal
por lo tanto pausa este vídeo y trata de
resolverlo muy bien trabajemos juntos en
esto hay muchas maneras en que podríamos
abordar esto una forma es darse cuenta
de que 5 dividido entre 2 podemos
expresar lo como 5 dividido entre dos o
como 5 medios y 5 medios es lo mismo que
41 sobre 2 que es lo mismo que 4 medios
más un medio que es lo mismo que 4
medios es igual a 2 y voy a hacer esto
en un color diferente
esta parte de aquí es 2 y luego tienes
este medio es lo mismo que 2 y un medio
y si expresáramos esto como un decimal
va a ser igual a 2 y cuantas décimas es
igual a un medio pues 5 décimas es igual
a un medio entonces 5 dividido entre 2
es igual a 2.5 ahora otra forma en la
que podrías resolverlo es 5 dividido
entre 2 es lo mismo que 50 décimas
divididas entre 2 de modo que en lugar
de cinco puedo decir que cinco es lo
mismo que cincuenta décimas cincuenta
décimas divididas entre dos y si tengo
cincuenta de algo y los tuviera que
dividir entre dos bueno eso dará como
resultado 25 de algo así que esto va a
ser igual a 25 décimas
y cómo podríamos expresar 25 décimas
como un decimal bueno voy a poner aquí
algunas posiciones entonces
definitivamente tenemos cinco décimas y
lo pondré en la posición de las décimas
y luego veinte décimas que es lo mismo
que dos unidades y eso es exactamente lo
mismo que teníamos aquí de cualquier
manera obtienes 2.5 dos unidades y cinco
décimas